[Musique]
savez-vous comment conduire un bâton Je suis vraiment
désolé, vous savez comment le changer ici
qu'est-ce qu'un engrenage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] d'
accord,
nous voulons juste parler de votre
petit ami mais il a largué  moi
juteux je suis désolé ce que certaines mauvaises personnes
sont après moi jamais après je ne sais pas
pourriez-vous sortir avec la colonne vertébrale je trouve que
c'est une clé USB vous devez l'avaler
avant qu'ils ne reviennent il n'y a pas de
retour en arrière pour nous
nous '  je suis semi-professionnel à ce stade
professionnel nous sommes professionnels
rêve juste de
minions juste le minion avec le seul
œil, elle l'a googlé sur mon ordinateur et
maintenant je reçois beaucoup d'annonces bizarres
[Musique]